um but i also want to point out
you can you can see this issue of
your conscious mind becoming a spectator
very well if you compare
tennis to table tennis
right if you watch a tennis game you
could
imagine that the players are highly
conscious as they play
you cannot imagine that if you've ever
played ping pong
decently a volley in ping ping-pong is
so fast
that your conscious mind if it had if
your reactions had to go through your
conscious mind
you wouldn't be able to play so you can
detect that your conscious mind
while very much present isn't there and
you can also detect where consciousness
does usefully intrude
if you go up against an opponent in
table tennis
that knows a trick that you don't know
how to respond
to you will suddenly detect that
something about your
game is not effective and you will start
thinking about what might be
how do you position yourself so that
move that puts the ball just in that
corner of the table or something like
that
doesn't catch you off guard and
this i believe is we
highly conscious folks those of us who
try to think through things very
deliberately and carefully
mistake consciousness for like the
highest kind of thinking
and i really think that this is an error
consciousness is an intermediate
level of thinking what it does is it
allows you it's basically like
uncompiled code
and it doesn't run very fast it is
capable of being adapted to new
circumstances but once the code
is roughed in right it gets driven into
the unconscious layer and you become
highly effective at whatever it is
and that from that point your conscious
mind basically remains there to detect
things that aren't anticipated by the
code you've already written
and so i don't exactly know how
one would establish this how one would
demonstrate it
but it must be the case that the human
mind
contains sandboxes in which things are
tested
right maybe you can build a piece of
code and run it in parallel
next to your active code so you can see
how it would have done
comparatively but there's got to be some
way of writing
new code and then swapping it in and
frankly i think this has a lot to do
with things like sleep
cycles very often you know when i get
good at something
i often don't get better at it while i'm
doing it i get better at it when i'm not
doing it especially if there's time to
sleep and think on it
so there's some sort of you know new
programs swapping in for old program
phenomenon
which um you know will be a lot easier
to see in machines
it's going to be hard with the the the
wet wear
i like i mean it is true because
somebody that played i played tennis for
many years
i do still think the highest form of
excellence in tennis
is when the conscious mind is a
spectator
so it's the compiled code is the
highest form of being human and then
consciousness
is just some like specific compiler
he has to have like borland c plus plus
compile
you could just have different kind of
compilers ultimately
the the thing that by which we measure
the the power of life the intelligence
of life is the compiled code
and you can probably do that compilation
all kinds of ways
yep yeah i'm not saying that tennis is
played consciously and
table tennis isn't i'm saying that
because tennis is slowed down by the
just
the space on the court you could you
could imagine that it was your conscious
mind playing
but when you shrink the court down it
was obvious it becomes obvious that your
conscious mind is just
present rather than knowing where to put
the battle and
weirdly for me um i would say this
probably isn't true in a podcast
situation
but if i have to give a presentation
especially if i have not overly prepared
i often find the same phenomenon when
i'm giving the presentation my conscious
mind is there watching some other part
of me present
which uh is a little jarring i have to
say
well that means you've you've gotten
good at it
not let the conscious mind get in the
way of the flow of words
yeah that's that's the sensation to be
sure and that's the highest form of
podcasting too i mean that's why i have
that's what it looks like when a podcast
is really in the pocket like
like joe rogan just having fun
and just losing themselves and that's
that's something i aspire to as well
just losing yourself in conversation
somebody that has a lot of anxiety with
people like i'm such an introvert
i'm scared i'm scared before you showed
up i'm scared right now um
there's just anxiety there's just it's a
giant mess
uh it's hard to lose yourself it's hard
to just
get out of the way of your own mind yeah
actually uh
trust is a big component of that your
your conscious mind retains control if
you
are very uncertain um but when you do
when you do get into that zone when
you're speaking
i realize it's different for you with
english as a second language although
maybe you present in russian and
you know and it happens but yeah do you
ever hear yourself say something and you
think
oh that's really good right like like
you didn't come up with it some other
part of you that you don't exactly know
came up with it i i don't think i've
ever
heard myself in that way because i have
a much louder voice
that's constantly yelling in my head at
why the hell did you say that there's a
very
self-critical voice that's much louder
so i'm very
um maybe i need to deal with that voice
but it's been like with without what is
it called like a megaphone just
screaming so i can't hear you oh no
good job you said that thing really
nicely so i'm kind of focused right now
on on the megaphone person
in the audience versus the deposit but
that's definitely something to think
about it's been productive
but you know the place where i find
gratitude
and beauty and appreciation of life is
in the quiet moments
when i don't talk when i listen to the
world around me when i listen to others
i'm when i talk i'm extremely
self-critical in my mind
when i when i produce anything out into
the world that's
that originated with me like any kind of
creation
extremely self-critical it's good for
productivity for like always striving to
improve and so on
it might be bad for for like
just appreciating the things you've
created i'm a little bit with marvin
minsky on this where he says the the key
to um to a productive life is to hate
everything you've ever done
in the past i didn't know he said that i
must say i resonate with it a bit
and you know i i unfortunately my life
currently has me putting a lot of stuff
into the world
and i effectively watch almost none of
it i can't stand it
yeah what what do you make of that i
don't know i just recently i just
yesterday
read um metamorphosis by cough reread
metamorphosis by kafka where he turns
into john bug
because of the stress that the world
puts on him
his parents put on him to succeed and
you know
i think that's you have to find the
balance because
if you if you allow the self-critical
voice to become too heavy the burden of
the world the pressure
that the world puts on you to be the
best version of yourself and so on to
strive
then you become a bug and that's a big
problem
and then uh and then every and then the
world turns against you
because you're a bug you become some
kind of caricature of yourself
uh i don't know become the worst version
of yourself
and then thereby end up destroying
yourself and then the world moves on
that's the story
that's a lovely story i do think
this is one of these places and frankly
you could
map this on to all of modern human
experience but this is one of these
places where
our ancestral programming does not serve
our modern selves
yeah so i used to talk to students about
the question of
dwelling on things you know dwelling on
things is famously
understood to be bad and it can't
possibly be bad
it wouldn't exist a tendency toward it
wouldn't exist if it was bad
so what is bad is dwelling on things
past the point
of utility and you know that's obviously
easier to say than to operationalize but
if you realize that your dwelling is the
key in fact to upgrading your program
for
future well-being and that there's a
point you know
presumably from diminishing returns if
not counter productivity
there is a point at which you should
stop because that is what is in your
best interest
then knowing that you're looking for
that point is useful
right this is the point at which it is
no longer useful for me to dwell on this
error i have made
right that is that's what you're looking
for and um
it also gives you license right if some
part of you feels like it you know is
punishing you rather than
searching then that also has a
point at which it's no longer valuable
and there's some liberty in realizing
yep even the part of me that was
punishing me knows it's time to stop
so if we uh map that onto compiled code
discussion as a computer science person
i find that very compelling
you know there's a when you compile
code you get warnings sometimes and um
usually if you're a good software
engineer you're going to
make sure there's no you know you treat
warnings as errors
so you make sure that the compilation
produces no warnings
but at a certain point when you have a
large enough system you just let the
warnings go
it's fine like i don't know where that
warning came from
but you know it's just ultimately you
need to compile the code and and run
with it
and i hope nothing terrible happens
you